we're decent people being driven from
our homes slaughtered in cold blood
sorry seek revenge
I seek righteousness but I'll take
revenge took a job let me put some men
to join me
difficult impossible and then you got so
far
you and me like only one a few help us
fight
quite a batch of strays what could go
wrong
what's the plan I'm always one of those
how many men you say
I have need of a man with your
qualification I'm not for sale
I'm a duly sworn Warrant Officer we need
your help worth decent people being
driven from our homes slaughtered in
cold blood
sorry seek revenge drastic righteousness
but I'll take revenge we're looking with
some men to a job difficult impossible
I need more than a few they help us
fight how many you got so far
allow me to show you something
I believe that bears wearing people's
clothes since we are bonding
quite a batch of strays you tell your
boss if he wants in town come see me
why are you here fighting someone else's
fight
if you don't deserve your lives back
take the damn shot
suppose that Undertaker's gonna get some
business out of this deal this is not
going to end we'll what
how many Moodle who say
you
sir I have a proposition work decent
people being driven from our homes
slaughtered in cold blood so you seek
revenge drastic righteousness but I'll
take revenge took a job looking for some
men to join me difficult
impossible
and then you got so far you and me
quite a batch of strays this is not
going to end we'll
yeah dang it I'm good
how many men you say
man carries a gun he tends to use it
Danny dead pity I had just ordered a
drink from that man took a job looking
for some men to join the difficult
impossible
how many you got so far you and me
Russia we work for her that's right
that man murdered and husband I want
something I take it he will take
everything with him
so you seek revenge I seek righteousness
but I'll take revenge on you mourn a few
elbows fight
what a bunch of misfits we are you know
how to shoot that thing
I'll do it it's all mine
look oh my friend oh good we got a
Mexican a sense we're bonding
Oh
we got seven he's got an army
and they'll be murdered by the world's
greatest lover why are you here hiding
someone else's fight these people
deserve a lies back just make sure we're
fighting the battle in front of us not a
bad one every man got the right to
choose wait dies we don't know where
else to go so
what's the point I'm always wanted to
blow something up it's not a plan
how'd we do I think we killed them all
yeah
and then you got so far you and me